Der 33. Spieltag der 2. Bundesliga der Männer ist ausgespielt und es hat sich die erwartet spannende Ausgangslage für das Saisonfinale ergeben. Ganze fünf Teams spielen noch um den Erstliga-Aufstieg, für drei Mannschaften geht es aber noch um den Klassenerhalt. Wer wird Zweitliga-Meister? Wer steigt auf? Wer steigt ab? All das jetzt mit Jan Lukas Elskamp und Michael Fischer. Let's go!
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor! Und Augsburg ist oben! Rossi zu Kurzabwehr, lang genug für Gilly Landgraf! Wargraf! Martin Wargraf!
Und das 1-0! Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl!
Alex hat den Schuh!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ich finde generell gut, dass hier immer– wir hatten sehr gelassene Sprachnachrichten und hier wurde doch mal direkt gezündet, sowohl was Nürnberg angeht, als auch was der FC angeht. Ja, also ich würde ganz kurz noch zu Elversberg ergänzen, weil er es ja auch angesprochen hat, und wir ist vorher sehr kurz nur in einem Beitrag gekommen, wo ich Sorge habe, dass da die Elversberger-Fans vielleicht sagen, dass es vielleicht ein bisschen kurz ist, dafür, dass sie ja wirklich gute Chancen haben, dass ich dieses Leihmodell von denen auch extrem spannend finde und dass man dadurch sich eben auch mal eben diese, meiner Meinung nach so wichtigen Unterschiedsspieler reinholen kann. Das ist bei Paderborn jetzt ein bisschen ein anderes Modell und trotzdem halte ich da die sportliche Führung seit Jahren im Prinzip für sehr fähig, man holt sehr gute Spieler rein, man hat trainerseitig sehr viel Konstanz, aber auch trotzdem irgendwie immer eine Weiterentwicklung. Ich wüsste gar nicht, wo ich jetzt die primäre Stärke von Paderborn sehen würde, weil sie sowohl mit dem Ball für mich sehr durchdacht wirken, als auch gegen den Ball berühmt berüchtigt sind. Also man könnte irgendwie in beide Richtungen argumentieren, dass es sehr stark ist und trotzdem sind dann doch irgendwie immer mal Spiele dabei, wo man überhaupt nicht versteht, warum die dann so ausgehen, zumal die Spiele gegen Köln waren jetzt auch nicht überragend. Man hatte das Spiel, hat Paderborn gewonnen und auch verdient gewonnen. Und das Rückspiel war dann eben so ein seltsames Spiel, wo der FC das Spiel irgendwie gedreht hat samt verschossenem Elfmeter von Paderborn. Und das war eben dann auch eines von diesen drei Spielen, was man verloren hat. Und doch sind sie jetzt wieder herangekommen. Und bei Paderborn tue ich mich wirklich am schwersten. Ich hätte eigentlich immer gesagt, das ist der größte Konkurrent um die Top 3. Weil ich sie eben in sehr vielen verschiedenen Bereichen sehr stark sehe. Und trotzdem würde ich genauso nicht ausschließen können, dass Karlsruhe da irgendwie nochmal einen schönen Saisonabschluss feiert und Paderborn die Seite zeigt, die ich nicht verstehe. Deswegen bin ich, was eine Einschätzung angeht, was Paderborn betrifft, total blank. Also ich kann in jedem Spiel immer ganz viel sehen. Und bin da vielleicht ein bisschen darauf angewiesen, dass ihr das mir erklären könnt, weil ich verstehe die nicht ganz.
Ja, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich kann es, also, ich glaube schon, dass Lukas Krasniok die Qualität hat, diese Mannschaft an ihr absolutes Optimum zu bringen. Aber dass dieses Optimum vielleicht unter dem liegt, was der HSV an Optimum haben kann oder Köln an Optimum haben kann und dass diese Schlagzahl so hoch ist, dass es dann auch mal Partien gibt, wo es vermeintlich unerklärlich dann nicht ganz reicht. Das war in der Rückrunde, zum Rückrundauftakt gegen Hertha auch so. Das hat Hertha das Spiel gewonnen. Also Hertha war bei Leipzig nicht die bessere Mannschaft, aber Paderborn hat sich gefühlt selbst einen Bein gestellt. Und ich glaube, da sind wir dann beim Thema individuelle Qualität und dass diese Mannschaft an ihr absolutes Limit kommen muss, um da oben mitspielen zu können. Und sobald sie dort nicht ankommen, sieht es vielleicht unerklärlich dilettantisch aus. Ja, aber das ist so mein einziger Erklärungsansatz. Ich glaube, daran nagte ja auch Lukas Krasniuk in die Saison, dass er immer sagt, ey, wir holen das Optimum raus, aber wir brauchen eigentlich noch mehr individuelle Qualität, um dieses Optimum noch höher schrauben zu können. Und das passiert nicht. Und das hat ihn ja genervt. Und ich glaube, das ist auch einer der Hauptpunkte, weshalb er diesen Verein verlassen wird, weil er dann noch bessere Spieler an seiner Seite haben will, um dann wieder mehr erreichen zu können.
Hast du alles, was ich sagen wollte, mir vorweggenommen? Also ich glaube tatsächlich, dass diese mangelnde, also mangelndes Blut beim Tabellen erfütten, aber die mangelnde Qualität einfach der Grund, warum Lukas Klassik öfter mal ausgetickt ist. Also es ist ja nicht das erste Mal gewesen, hat er auch unter anderem zwei Tore, der verkrault in dieser Saison schon. Weil er halt einfach immer wieder so erfolgsbesessen ist. Man kann das ja positiv sehen. Das war in Fürth mit Alexander Zorniger ganz ähnlich, wenn man einen Trainer hat, der erfolgsbesessen ist. Und dann kämpft er halt gegen alles an, was diesem Erfolge im Wege steht in irgendeiner Form und in einer Mannschaft, die halt einfach auch darauf setzt, kluge Transfers zu tätigen aus unteren Ligen, dass sich Spieler entwickeln. Und Entwicklung verläuft halt nicht immer linear. Und wenn dann Spieler mal in ihrer Entwicklung drei schlechte Spiele machen und man hat einen Trainer mit Lukas Quasniewijk, der aber halt aufsteigen will, ganz klar, dann kommt das halt mal vor und dann konnte das auch nicht allzu gut verbergen. Aber trotzdem möchte ich auch noch mal unterstreichen, dass Paderborn auch wie Elvesberg sehr kluge Transfers tätigt. Zwar etwas andere Strategie, aber da schaue ich mittlerweile aus, wird auch manchmal etwas neidvoll nach Paderborn, wie gut man da die Transfers tätigt.
Definitiv. Haben wir auch so ein bisschen das Fürther-Modell übernommen, auch mal einen Spieler überraschend aus der 4. oder 3. Liga ranzuholen und dann sehr schnell auf Zweitliganiveau zu bekommen und teilweise dann darüber hinaus. Und ich möchte es bei Elvesberg auch überhaupt nicht unterschlagen. Also ich bin absolut baff, was die diese Saison machen. Also ich hatte ja auch den Zweitligaschwerpunkt mit Elvesberg. Da haben wir lange darüber geredet, wie absolut irre das ist, wie die aus der 4. in die Zweitliga hochgeschossen kamen und auch jetzt eben ganz realistische Chancen haben, hochzugehen. Das ist schon einigermaßen irre. Gut, dann, nächster Verein. Auch Fortuna Düsseldorf hat noch ein Wörtchen, nämlich im Rennen, um den Relegationsrang zumindest mitzureden. Die 95er sind jetzt seit sechs Spielen umgeschlagen. Übrigens wieder KSC, weshalb es auch für Paderborn schwer werden könnte, da die haben seit Februar zu Hause nicht mehr verloren. Aber zurück zu Düsseldorf, die sind eben auch seit sechs Spielen umgeschlagen und haben sich so noch einmal an diese Aufstiegsringe irgendwie so heran gerobbt, habe ich das Gefühl. Es stehen jetzt eben zwei Zähler hinter Elbersberg und Paderborn. Und ob Düsseldorf noch an die zweite Aufstiegsreligation in Folge glaubt, muss man ja sagen, erzählt uns Gianni Koster von der Rheinischen Post.
Nach dem Relegationsdrama in der vergangenen Saison, wo Fortuna Düsseldorf ja gegen den VfL Bochum gescheitert ist, könnte es in diesem Jahr ja einen Widersinn geben in der Relegation. Fortuna hat sich tatsächlich ein Endspiel erkämpft, was man selber zwar nicht mehr so in der eigenen Hand hat, aber immerhin, kleines Endspiel ist es. Ja, am letzten Spieltag gegen Magdeburg könnte es wieder ein Relegationsplatz werden. Tatsächlich hat man in diesem Jahr ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass die Düsseldorfer weniger zu verlieren haben, als man das so in der vergangenen Saison bei dem einen oder anderen gewähnt hat. Und die Stimmung ist relativ entspannt, weil man natürlich weiß, dass die Konkurrenz jetzt da schon ordentlich patzen muss, damit man noch mal eine Chance hat, wirklich oben anzuklopfen. Aber weil man auch sich selber eingesteht, dass diese Saison ja richtig, richtig wild gewesen ist, ein Wilder wird sehr, sehr unkonstant, was man aber allerdings natürlich auch mit vielen, vielen anderen Konkurrenten teilt. Von daher muss man sich natürlich nicht schämen, wo man jetzt steht. Am Ende, ja, für was wird es lang? Mein persönlicher Tipp ist, es wird drama pur, weil das einfach Fortuna-DNA pur ist. Heißt also möglicherweise ein Sieg in Magdeburg. Aber ob das dann reichen wird? Ich habe da so meine argen Bedenken und tippe auf ein Last-Minute-Tor noch von Elbersberg auf Schalke. Wodurch dann die Elbersberger sich in die Relegation begeben würden. Für Düsseldorf wäre das in diesem Fall schade, aber kein echtes Drama. Denn man hat nicht wirklich einkalkuliert, nach diesen wirklich Tränen aus in der Relegation in der vergangenen Saison, dass es diesmal für ganz oben reichen kann. Und wenn man ganz ehrlich ist, es gab Mannschaften, die sind auch schon an solchen Erlebnissen zerbrochen. Umso ehrbarer ist es, dass sich Fortuna aufgerappelt hat und in eine Situation gebracht hat, die man so lange nicht für möglich gehalten hat. Von daher, Daniel Thun hat gesagt, mit Blick auf das letzte Spiel, der Druck sei noch längst nicht abgefallen, denn man wolle noch was erreichen. Die Saison ist nicht vorbei und das hört man auch von allen Spielern so. Die glauben noch an ihre Mini-Chance, was am Ende dabei herausspringt, man wird es sehen. Grüße aus Düsseldorf.
Vielen lieben Dank. Jan Lukas, wie blickst du denn auf die Saison auf der anderen Reihenseite? Zwischenzeitig hatte man das Gefühl, dass Düsseldorf durch diese Liga schweben könnte. Am Anfang sind die gefühlt davon geritten und dann kam es zur erwähnten Inkonstanz. Glaubst du, dass Düsseldorf es noch ziehen kann oder ist das jetzt doch ein Spieltagverschluss, denn doch eine zu große Hypothek?
Ich glaube, da muss zu viel für passieren. Ich glaube, man kann Düsseldorf glücklich sein, aber es klang in der Mimimi auch durch, dass es noch um was geht. Ich habe die Mannschaft in dieser Saison nicht stark genug empfunden, auch wenn es diesen guten Start gab. Ich finde, man hat sehr stark gemerkt, dass viel von Solis letztes Jahr abgehangen hat. Auch da wieder Stichwort, ich sage es vielleicht heute zu oft, aber ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, man braucht einen überragenden Spieler in seiner Mannschaft. Und das in dieser Liga sehr viel hilft. Und ich habe Düsseldorf in diesem Jahr, muss ich sagen, auch vielleicht geprägt durch die Spiele gegen den FC, wo man zweimal als Köln deutlich stärker war. Und das ist bestimmt nur ein bisschen mein Blick, weil so viel und so gerne ich auch Einzelspiele von der zweiten Gellkucke man doch immer im Besonderen oder den Bias sehr stark daran hat, wie spielt der Verein gegen meinen Verein, beziehungsweise mir geht das so. Da war Düsseldorf zweimal ziemlich wach. Und letzten Endes glaube ich einfach, dass die Mannschaft dieses Jahr nicht stark war oder stark genug war. Ich finde, man braucht sich da auch dann nicht schämen. Ich fand den Punkt sehr gut, dass es halt emotional nach so einer verlorenen Relegation wirkt. Also da muss man wirklich erstmal oben mitspielen nochmal. Und das hat man geschafft. Da schafft es der Trainer auch glaube ich sehr viel Ruhe reinzukriegen mit Dundale Tune. Ja und dann ist es halt eine Saison, die einfach wahrscheinlich auch keinem so richtig wehtut. Also ich denke nicht, dass man da jetzt irgendwie unzufrieden ist, dass das Umfeld groß mehr erwartet hätte. Natürlich wäre man glücklich gewesen. Und ich kann mir aber jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass entweder Elversberg auf Schalke oder Paderborn in Karlsruhe einer von beiden vielleicht doch ein bisschen auf einmal etwas zu verlieren hat. Wobei eigentlich haben die nichts zu verlieren. Aber der mentale Druck dann doch vielleicht ein bisschen groß. Aber das Beide patzen sehe ich eigentlich nicht, weil beide wirklich zu stark dafür sind. Und dementsprechend gehe ich nicht mehr davon aus, dass Düsseldorf oben noch mit spielt. Auch wenn es natürlich ein spannendes Bild wäre, wenn Düsseldorf wieder Relegation spielen würde. Aber ich glaube, das wird nicht so kommen.
Köln und Düsseldorf Hand in Hand nach oben, wäre das nicht schön.
Mit Blick auf die Tord-Differenz müssen wir auch sagen, es müssten ja auch Erwesberg und Paderborn verlieren. Also entschieden, der eine der beiden Teams würde ja schon reichen, um dann auf Platz 3 zu bleiben, weil die Vertuner wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht entweder 6 oder 19 Tore aufholen wird.
Das stimmt. Aber wie gesagt, es würde nicht im ähnlich tiefen Tal der Tränen enden. Wahrscheinlich hätte er auch nicht gedacht, dass die da oben direkt wieder mitspielen. Die haben im Sommer ja nicht nur Solis verloren, sondern sie haben Jannik Engelhardt verloren, der nach Como gewechselt ist. Aotanakka ist nach England gewechselt. Es gab dann auch so Spieler, die vielleicht auch erst im Winter. Felix Klaus gewechselt sind zu Kräuter Fürth. Er ist im Winter gewechselt, richtig?
Der Fürther Junge kam im Winter nach Hause. So wurde das tituliert.
So ist die Formulierung. Stimmt. Darauf haben wir jetzt geeinigt. Nein, aber dementsprechend gab es da ja offensichtlich einen größeren Umbruch. Sie haben auch viele junge Spieler dazugeholt. Und dass das dann erst mal so zündet, hat vielleicht wieder gewisse Erwartungen geweckt. Aber wenn die am Ende die Saison dann eben rund um Platz 5 beenden, dann ist das, finde ich, für Fortuna Düsseldorf eine völlig okaye Saison. Zumal das ja auch gleichzeitig bedeutet, sie haben keinen Druck vom letzten Spieltag. Sie müssen jetzt auch nichts mehr erreichen. Sie wollen es erreichen. Das ist, glaube ich, die fast schönere Ausgangslage. Da geht man dann vielleicht etwas unverkampft an dieses letzte Spiel gegen Magdeburg, die zwar ein starker Gegner sind, doch eben auch einer, der in den letzten Wochen einen sichtlichen Formabfall ertragen musste. Also da ist schon durchaus was möglich. Ja, und was ist noch möglich für den letzten Club, der sich für solch ein spannendes Aufstiegsfinale qualifiziert hat, nämlich den ersten FC Kaiserslautern auf Tabellenplatz 6, ebenfalls zwei Punkte hinter Elversberg und Paderborn, also dementsprechend eine quasi identische Ausgangslage. Ja, die Roten Teufel haben extra für den Saisonentsport und das Aufstiegsticket vor drei Spieltagen den Trainer nochmal gewechselt. Thorsten Dieberknecht folgte überraschend auf Markus Anfang. Und ob diese Wette der FCK-Führung aufgegangen ist und ob man auf dem Betze noch an den Tabellenplatz 3 glaubt, erzählt uns nun Moritz Kreilinger vom Kicker.
Liebe Rasenfunk-Zuhörende, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber ich hatte vor dieser Saison sicherlich nicht auf meiner Fußball-Bingo-Karte stehen lassen, dass der FCK am 34. Spieltag noch die Chance auf den Relegationsplatz hat und auch Friedhelm Funkel in diesem Szenario wieder eine entscheidende Rolle spielt. Ja, nur diesmal halt nicht als Trainer vom FCK, sondern vom kommenden Gegner Köln. Aber ich glaube, die Aufstiegsträume in Kaiserslautern, die sind nicht mehr ganz so groß, weil das Szenario kennt ja jeder. Und es müsste ja sehr, sehr viel zusammenkommen. Elvesberg und Paderborn haben beide das deutlich bessere Torverhältnis. Das heißt, sie müssten ihre Partien verlieren am 34. Spieltag. Düsseldorf gleichzeitig darf nicht gewinnen. Naja, und man selbst muss halt auch noch gewinnen, und zwar gegen Köln. Und genau das war halt in dieser Saison das Problem vom FCK, dass er gegen die Spitzen-Teams zu wenig Punkte geholt hat. Von den fünf Mannschaften, die aktuell in der Tabelle vor dem FCK spielen, hat der FCK in zehn Spielen nur drei Spiele gewonnen. Das ist halt einfach zu wenig. Es ist so ein bisschen paradox zu den letzten Jahren, wo Kaiserslautern regelmäßig gegen die kleineren Teams und die, die im Tabellenkeller standen, gestolpert sind. Und das hat sich dieses Jahr so ein bisschen verändert. Vor der Saison hätte, glaube ich, jeder dieses Szenario, das es jetzt gibt, mit Kusshand genommen. Aber so nach dem Saisonverlauf ist es jetzt doch, glaube ich, so eine leichte Enttäuschung, weil es war einfach mehr drin. Man hätte mit dem einen oder anderen Punkt quasi jetzt schon den sicheren Aufstieg in der Tasche haben können. Und ja, denn Markus Anfang hat dann diese drei Spiele in Serie verloren, woraufhin er dann gehen musste. Thorsten Lieberknecht ist jetzt sieben Punkte aus drei Spielen. Das klingt jetzt erst mal sehr gut. Ob es mit Markus Anfang mehr oder weniger geworden wären, das werden wir nie erfahren. Aber die Mannschaft hat jetzt in den letzten drei Wochen auch nicht überzeugt spielerisch. Lieberknecht hat relativ wenig verändert, was das Personal angeht und auch mehr oder weniger die Grundformation übernommen. Es ist vielleicht ein bisschen der Unterschied, während Markus Anfang ja so ein Fußball-Ideologe ist, der so seine Spielidee auf eine Mannschaft übertragen will, ist Thorsten Lieberknecht eher so ein Pragmatiker. Der schaut, was er hat und was er damit umsetzen kann. Vielleicht ist es genau das, was die Mannschaft in den letzten Wochen gebraucht hat. Zumindest diese sieben Punkte einzufahren, um sich die Minimalschance für den 34. Spieler in Köln noch aufrechtzuerhalten. Aber, wie gesagt, es müsste viel zusammenkommen. Dann sind wir mal gespannt. Es wird im Sommer auf jeden Fall einen größeren Umbruch geben. Der FCK hat einige Leihspieler in seinem Kader. Der FCK hat mit Ragnar Ache und Daisuki Yokota zwei Offensivspieler, der eine ist geliehen. Ache wird wahrscheinlich den Verein verlassen, weil Angebote sind auf jeden Fall da. Das heißt, der FCK wird nächstes Jahr ein anderes Gesicht zeigen. Ich schätze, dass es in der 2. Liga sein wird.
Vielen Dank für die Einschätzung, Jan Lukas. Ragnar Ache, ich habe gehört, der möchte Bundesliga spielen. Wäre das nicht jemand als Knipser?
Ja, ich habe von einem anderen Gast gehört, dass die SV Elbersberg da Interesse haben würde. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich kann jetzt noch keine Transfergerüchte zu Bundesligaspielern ernst nehmen. Das wäre natürlich jemand, der Tore schießen würde, im besten Fall. Genauso ist es aber in der Trainerposition, dass es jemand wird, der unbedingt Bundesliga coachen will. Ach, es ist sicherlich jemand, der dann eine gewisse Komponente in diesem Spiel sein wird, weil er eben dieses nachgesagte FC-Interesse hat. Das wäre natürlich dann ein Kuriosum der Geschichte, wenn da etwas passieren würde.
Geschichten, die wirklich ausschließlich der Fußball schreit.
Man könnte eine Tasse darüber entwerfen. Ich glaube, das hörte sich sehr nach 2. Liga-Aufstiegs-Aspirant an, dass man denkt, hätten wir da mal eine Phase weggelassen, dann hätten wir einfach diese zwei Punkte mehr, dann wäre alles anders.
Die 2. Liga ist auch die Liga der verpassten Chancen.
Genau, das ist genau das. Wir haben es bei Paderborn gehabt, wir haben es bei Düsseldorf gehabt, beim FC sowieso. Alle Mannschaften haben auch in 2025 noch irgendwie eine Phase drin gehabt, wo man denkt, warum so. Und ich fand trotzdem, dass es irgendwie spannend klang, mit Thorsten Nieberknecht als felsische Friedhelm Funke. So einfach pragmatisch, das was da ist, bisschen noch mal mitnehmen und gucken, was so geht. Die Konzentration ist natürlich wirklich so, dass man einfach, sobald es sobald Elbersberg oder Paderborn führen in der zweiten Halbzeit, das ich da auch schon vorstellen könnte, weil sowas kommt ja dann doch. Wahrscheinlich wird es der FC auch durchsagen. Wobei, für einen FC ist ja auch schlecht. Aber wenn lautern, dann weiß, dass es vielleicht doch nicht mehr um alles geht, dass man dann so ein bisschen vielleicht auf enttäuschte, rote Teufel setzt, wenn es irgendwie gerade nicht läuft. Aber andererseits wird es dann die Stimmung auch wieder schlecht machen. Ich weiß es nicht. Es muss so viel passieren. Und da fand ich die Einschätzung auch eigentlich treffend. Wie sollte ich es mir auch anders anmaßen, wenn da jemand so nah am Verein ist? Ich fürchte, für lautern wird es jetzt nicht mehr um den Aufstieg gehen. Aber man weiß ja nie.
Michael, jetzt wurde aber ja mehr oder weniger genau für den Aufstieg der Trainer gewechselt. Also man hat ja schon sehr auf dieses Momentum gesetzt, um das noch irgendwie zu packen. Sonst hätte man ja die Saison mit Markus Anfang zu Ende bringen können, der sie ja auch erst in diese Situation gebracht hat. Das ist ja auch das Paradox an der Situation. Ja, er hat vielleicht drei Spiele verloren, aber ansonsten hat er ja so viele Siege geholt und so begeisternden Fußball im Vergleich zur Vorsaison spielen lassen, dass man überhaupt in der Lage erst mal war. Wie blickst du denn auf so Trainerwechsel kurz vorm Ende?
Also der Zusatz im Vergleich zur letzten Saison war wichtig, weil begeisternd fand ich den FCK jetzt nicht immer.
Ich wollte das Bild aufmachen. Davor waren da so Leute wie Friedhelm Funkel, wie Graham Motzes. Das ist dann schon ein Kontrastprogramm.
Ja, und das hat ja auch gedauert. Also es war ja klar, dass so eine Mannschaft, die jetzt nicht wirklich für gepflegten Ballbesitzfußball steht, dann zu einer Ballbesitzfußballmannschaft wird, die auch betont guten Fußball spielen soll aufgrund des Trainers. Ich war da Anfang im August mal letzten Jahres. Da waren sie einfach richtig schlecht. Da hätte man niemand gedacht, dass sie der FCK bis zum letzten Spieltag da oben mitspielen kann. Insofern war die Entwicklung ja eine sehr positive dieser Mannschaft. Und man muss ja immer auch denken, woher der FCK kommt. Also natürlich träumen alle von diversen Meisterschaften und so weiter. Aber der FCK kommt aus der dritten Liga und war da im Abgrund zur vierten Liga sogar. Das haben wir zu Genüge schon besprochen in früheren Folgen. Insofern war das ja eigentlich für die Entwicklung eines Vereins eine sehr gute Saison bis dahin. Und natürlich muss man aber auch sagen, FCK gibt es wahrscheinlich. Da fehlen jetzt die ganz tiefen Einblicke. Aber es gibt halt auch Kräfte im Hintergrund, die vielleicht auch wollen, dass man unbedingt aufsteigt, weil man halt einfach viel Geld da schon investiert hat. Es gibt FCK-Investoren aus den USA und kann man schon gut vorstellen, dass einer mal sagt, jetzt haben wir die Chance, dann ergreifen wir sie bitte auch. Ist nicht klug, ist vielleicht auch wieder ein Lehrbeispiel, warum man keine Investoren haben sollte in einem Verein. Aber man hat die Chance weggeworfen auf eine lineare weitere Entwicklung. Andererseits, klar, wie angesprochen, werden auch wichtige Spieler gehen, und dass Ragnar Ache und Jukota wichtige Spieler sind. Das hat jeder gesehen, der zwei, drei Spiele vom FCK gesehen hat in der Saison. Und vor allem Ragnar Ache. Wir haben vorhin das Scouting in Fürth angesprochen. Lemperle war in Fürth, Ragnar Ache war auch mal in Fürth und hat da auch schon nachgewiesen, dass er ein sehr guter Stürmer sein kann. Insofern denkt man sich manchmal auch, was wäre gewesen, wenn diese Spiele alle noch da wären. Aber gut, das sollte man nicht tun.
Das denkt man bei Fürth sowieso. Da war ja gefühlt Halbfußball Deutschland. Also Fabi Rehsumko ja auch.
Oder David Rauhm als Linksverteidiger. Ja, ja.
Ja, wir könnten die Liste ewig weitergehen. Das spricht ja auch für den Verein. Aber gleichzeitig muss man ja auch sagen, man hat sich mit Thorsten Dieberknecht jemanden ins Haus geholt, der ja auch schon bewiesen hat, dann auch mit Mannschaften im längeren Sinne auf einen Aufstieg hinarbeiten zu können. Das ist im Braunschweig so gewesen, das war bei Darmstadt so. Also nur, weil die Saison vielleicht nicht im Aufstieg endet, muss man jetzt nicht sich denken, oh Gott, und wen haben wir jetzt auf der Trainerbank sitzen? Sondern da sitzt ja jemand, der sogar noch extra viel Identifikation mit dem Betze ja auch mitbringt, als er den Spieler dort gekickt, aber der eben als Trainer auch bewiesen hat, dass er es packen kann.
Zumal die Trainerentlassung von Marius Anfang, das soll jetzt kein belieber Witz werden. Kurz vor Ende der Saison ist nun mal auch ein Zeichen, dass da irgendwas auch oft nicht im Reinen ist. Also ich glaube, das ist auch schon fordernd. Wir haben das vorhin von Krasniok gehört, der Öffentlichspieler anzählt. Bei Anfang hört man das zwar nach außen nicht unbedingt oft, aber man hört immer bzw. auch in der Kölner Zeit war immer klar, da war die Stimmung aber nicht gerade positiv. Und wenn man da doch im internen das Gefühl hat, dass man, weil man brauchte ja schon so eine gewisse Aufbruchstimmung, dass man sagt, ja komm, wir greifen das nochmal an.
Ja.
Und das glaube ich schon, dass man da inhaltlich oder innerhalb der Mannschaft vielleicht auch zu zweifeln kommen kann, zumal lieber Knecht dann ja sogar auch eine langfristige Erfahrung hat aufzusteigen.
Und bei ihm muss man auch sagen, also bei Markus Anfang muss man auch sagen, es gibt ja auch die Gerüchte, dass er sich in dieser Zeit, in der er der Entscheidung gefallen ist, ja auch schon bei anderen Vereinen umgehört haben soll und eventuell auch selber schon bereit war, den Verein im Sommer zu verlassen. Also da spielt natürlich immer viel mit rein, das ist definitiv so.
Außerdem glaubt man wahrscheinlich in Kaiserslautern auch an die Kraft der Geschichte. Man hat ja vor dem Zweitliga-Aufstieg auch kurz zuvor seinen Trainer entlassen nochmal. Vielleicht hofft man, das wiederholen zu können.
Aber das hat jetzt insgesamt das dritte Mal gebracht. Diese Kurzschlussreaktion nenne ich es jetzt mal. Und das hat jetzt, ich würde behaupten, ja, ist schwierig zu sagen. Es hat einmal geklappt, einmal definitiv nicht geklappt. Und jetzt ist das so ein Mischding. Also es steht unentschieden, diese Bilanz. Nun gut. Apropos Bilanz, wir gucken jetzt, nehme ich mal darauf, wie unsere Tipps denn aussehen für die ersten drei Plätze der Abschlusstabelle. Das haben wir jetzt lange genug besprochen. Und ich finde, Butter bei die Fische, wir müssen uns dann irgendwas messen lassen. Jan Lukas, möchtest du mal beginnen? Wie wird dann die Abschlusstabelle zumindest auf den ersten drei Plätzen aussehen? Danach ist ja jetzt nicht so wichtig.
Ich glaube, dass der FC gewinnt gegen Kaiserslautern. Und das soll nicht heißen, oh ja, der arrogannte Kölner, sondern ich könnte es mir einfach vorstellen. Das ist definitiv realistisch. Ich kann mir sehr gut eine Welt vorstellen, in der irgendwas nicht klappt. Ich glaube aber daran, dass der FC gewinnt. Ich glaube auch, dass der HSV, ja, also Führt ist ja quasi durch, oder? Da kommen wir gleich zu dir, ich sitze ja auch nicht durch. Dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass der HSV schon ein bisschen zu viel gefeiert hat, dass Führt was holt gegen den HSV. Und dass dementsprechend der FC Zweitliga-Meister wird. Das hat sich Marc auch für sein Karriereende gewünscht, dass er mit der Zweitliga-Rattkappe abtreten wird. Das wäre vielleicht ein Highlight, aber gut. Und dementsprechend muss ich ja dann den FC als Zweitliga-Meister tippen. Den HSV auf zwei, ja, und auf drei. Ich kann mir, wie gesagt, sowohl bei Elbersberg als auch bei Paderborn vorstellen, dass das nicht gut geht. Ich bin ja echt, das darf ich öffentlich gar nicht sagen, aber ich bin ja, was den FC Schalke 04 angeht, nicht nur abgeneigt und ich schaue mir da sehr gerne Spiele an. Und ich fände es doch irgendwie schön, wenn man…
Moment, Moment, Moment. Du schaust dir gerne Schalke-Spiele an. Was ist passiert?
Da taumen immer 70.000 Verrückte hin. Und ich finde das so super. Es ist immer so gute Stimmung. Und auch dank meiner Schalke, oder Kontakte zu Schalke-Fans, die es da überall gibt, habe ich, ich versuche gerade eine Formulierung zu finden, die mir nicht hinterher als Kachel ausgelegt werden kann. Ich finde, da kann man Sympathien zu pflegen. So, das war jetzt lang genug unterbrochen, der Satz. Dementsprechend gehe ich einfach mal davon aus, dass Elbersberg irgendwie was liegen lässt, obwohl ich sie eigentlich für eine der stärksten Mannschaften halte und sehe dann Paderborn entsprechend auf Platz 3. Köln und der S04, jetzt sage ich es doch.
Das werden die Kölner Ultras nicht so schön finden, Köln und der S04, angesichts ihrer Freundschaften.
Das ist dementsprechend ja auch so.
Lass du dich mal nicht beim Daydrinking erwischen, lieber. So, Michi, wie sieht es aus?
Tja, der HSV wird Zweitliga-Meister, das sage ich hiermit. Und dann, ja, hier, Lukas Wecker. Und ich sage dir, der HSV Elvesberg wird Zweiter und der FC wird Dritter.
Okay, okay. Dann haben wir alle unterschiedliche Tipps. Das ist doch richtig schön. Denn ich glaube auch, dass der HSV Zweitliga-Meister wird. Ich glaube, die werden jetzt zwar viel feiern, aber ich glaube, dass die auch nochmal schön mit Druck in diese Partie gehen und die wollen das jetzt. Also die wollen jetzt alles haben. Die wollen jetzt alles haben. Die wollen auch nochmal die 60-Punkte-Marke, glaube ich, durchbrechen. Ich glaube, die haben Bock und ich glaube, die gewinnen dieses Spiel. Dann glaube ich, dass der FC gegen Kaiserslautern unentschieden spielen wird und dementsprechend möglichst knapp diesen zweiten Platz verteidigen wird. Und dann glaube ich tatsächlich, dass Elbersberg Schalke wegfiedeln wird und dementsprechend den dritten Platz verteidigt und wir dann die wirklich sehr glorreiche, rein vom Namen her glorreiche Relegation Heidenheim gegen Elbersberg bekommen. Der 1. Liga graut schon vor den TV-Quoten. Und das ist mein Tipp an der Stelle. Und dann gehen halt Paderborn, Düsseldorf und Lautern leer aus. Na ja. Gut, dann haben wir tatsächlich die erste Hälfte dieser Folge besprochen, wobei die zweite Hälfte, rein thematische Hälfte, denke ich mal kürzer gefasst wird, allein weil nicht mehr so viele Teams daran beteiligt sind. Wir reden jetzt über das Abstiegs-Rennen. Kann man das erwarten? Es ist eher der Abstiegskampf, seien wir ehrlich. Auch hier hole ich euch noch einmal ab. Der Jan aus Regensburg war ja bereits lange vor dem 33. Spieltag offiziell abgestiegen. Hier gibt es also keine Neuigkeiten mehr, außer dass Trainer Andreas Patz und Regensburg schon vor dem Spiel getrennte Wege gingen. Regensburg wollte zur neuen Saison eigentlich den Trainer wechseln. Dann hat Patz gesagt, jut, dann mach ich die letzten beiden Spiele aber bitte auch nicht mehr. Und dann saß eben sein Co-Trainer auf der Bank beim 2. Zweiten Spiel gegen KSC. Mit dem SSV Ulm ist nun auch der zweite offizielle Absteiger gefunden. Die 1 zu 6 Klatsche beim HSV besiegelte die direkte Rückkehr in Liga 3. Also zwei von drei Drittliga-Aufsteigern sind damit wieder in der dritten Liga angekommen. Vor dem letzten Spieltag sind es sechs Punkte auf den 16. Tabellenplatz. Das wird nichts mehr. Michi, vielleicht hole ich dich da aber kurz nochmal ab. Wie fandest du denn Ulm als Aufsteiger?
Sie haben es erstaunlich gut gemacht, fand ich, über viele Strecken. Aber auch da sieht man, dass die individuelle Qualität einfach nicht reicht. Das war in vielen Spielen so. Man denkt nur an die Letzten. Also sie waren beim HSV anfangs gut, hätten da deutlich schon mal führen können, hätten ein Elfmeter reinmachen können. Sie waren in der Woche zuvor gegen Hannover gut, hatten auch, wenn man auf die Daten schaut, deutlich bessere Daten in diesem Spiel eigentlich. Aber wenn man halt dann auch in zwei Spielen zwei Eigentore schießt, das sind halt auch so Zutaten, aus denen ein Abstieg gemacht ist.
Sie haben auch gegen Hertha geführt und das verdient. Und dann hat Hertha den Doppelschlag nach der Halbzeit gemacht und plötzlich das Ding 3-2 gezogen und am Ende mit einem Freistoß-Tor noch. Also, es war viel eng.
Ja, aber sie haben es im Rahmen ihrer Möglichkeiten gut gemacht. Sie haben sich auch als Mannschaft gut entwickelt. Ich fand es auch krass. Also, für mich kam dieser Trainerwechsel weg von Wörle erstmal überraschend, weil er ja doch der Architekt ist oder der Architekt des Ulmer Erfolgs der letzten Jahre war. Ich halte ihn auch immer noch für einen sehr fähigen Trainer. Ich wüsste einen Verein, der nach einem Trainer sucht, im Sommer. Vielleicht kommt er hierher. Aber das hat er doch nochmal früchte getragen mit Lechleiter. Man hat dann nochmal gewonnen. Man hat auch in Fürth gewonnen. Sehr schmerzhaftes Spiel, weil das war wirklich von beiden einfach nicht gut. Aber Maurice Grattemacher, die Leihgabe des FC Bayern. Klingt zwar komisch, aber ist ja von Nachricht zum FC Bayern gegangen. Auch wenn er da wahrscheinlich nichts in der nächsten Saison mitnehmen muss, ja, das spielen wird. Aber sie hatten auch individuelle Klasse. Celalovic soll auch beim 1. FC Nürnberg in Gespräche zahlen, also wird der Liga wahrscheinlich auch erhalten. Okay, na, schau an. Aber Hertha hat auch schon Gröning aus Ingolstadt geholt, also braucht es ja noch einen Stürmer.
Aber es gehen ja auch gleichzeitig 17 Stürmer, also wir brauchen noch einen Stürmer.
Okay, okay, okay. Ja, dann wechselt er eben zu Hertha.
Also, wenn es nach dem Minigate unterschreibt, sowieso Halb-Ulm in Berlin, denn Niklas Kolbe ist ja quasi schon verpflichtet, da steht nur noch die Verkündung aus. Celalovic soll ein Thema sein und auch Aaron Keller, der aber eigentlich bei Unterharring kickt.
Und Aaron Keller ist aber auch bei der spielfreundlichen Info. Am Gespräch sagt Sky. Und wenn Sky das sagt, dann wird es ja stimmen.
Ich nehme das auch stark an.
Ja, also sie haben es gut gemacht, Konklusio. Aber es hat halt am Ende aufgrund der individuellen Qualität und aufgrund des Glücks, was man vielleicht auch braucht, um drin zu bleiben, nicht gereicht. Aber ich glaube auch, das ist jetzt keine Überraschung, dass Ulm absteigt. Sie haben sich damit wahrscheinlich dann auch irgendwann noch jetzt dann in dieser Woche irgendwann mal abgefunden, nachdem es doch immer hart war. Genau, dieses 1-6 wahrscheinlich auf Schalke. Auf Schalke sage ich schon, beim HSV.
Das kann nicht gewesen sein.
Nein, das ist nicht passiert. Schalke hat keine 6 Tore geschossen in der Saison. Oder? Doch. Sie haben gegen Magdeburg mal so ein hohes Spiel gehabt. Oder war das schon letzte Saison? Heieiei. Es verschwimmt alles in dieser 2. Liga. Wie auch immer, die Ulmer werden damit klarkommen. Sie sind ja erst in die 3. Liga gekommen in der vorvergangenen Saison. Insofern sind sie jetzt wieder da, wo sie in der letzten Saison waren. Ist okay und war trotzdem eine Bereicherung für die Liga. Vor allem, ich muss auch sagen, fan-technisch fand ich das gut. Es waren immer sehr viele Menschen mit unterwegs. Da war schon ein Hype zu spüren. Wenn man denkt, ich hab mal ein bisschen Bilder angeguckt, wie das noch vor einigen Jahren in Ulm war. Da war noch nicht so viel los. Insofern wurde da vielleicht auch der schlafende Riese geweckt.
Davon gibt es auch einige in Deutschland.
Natürlich, natürlich. Man muss doch hier im Sportjournalisten sprechen bleiben.
Apropos schlafender Riese, Schalke 04, da reden wir natürlich auch gerne nochmal drüber, denn es sind eigentlich nur noch drei Vereine, für die es effektiv noch um den Klassenerhalt geht. Rechnerisch aber 4, denn Schalke 04 hat auch gegen Düsseldorf verloren. In den letzten fünf Spielen nur einen Zähler geholt. Und einen Spieltag vor Schluss ist man nur drei Punkte vor Rang 16. Allerdings, die Tordifferenz ist so gut in Anführungsstrichen im Vergleich zumindest, dass es am Ende reichen wird, selbst wenn man gegen Elbersberg verlieren sollte. Außer Elbersberg packen 15 zu Null aus, dann wird es nochmal eng. Aber wir gehen erstmal nicht davon aus. Wir gehen erstmal nicht davon aus. Aber dass es überhaupt zu solchen Rechenspielen kommen muss bei Schalke, zeigt, wie katastrophal diese Königsblaue Saison verlaufen ist. Ich glaube aber, Schalke wird hier kein Schwerpunkt in dieser Sendung. Das werden dann zukünftige Folgen wieder regeln. Wir möchten über die Spielvereinigung– ach nee, guck mal Jan Lukas, der muss was zu seinen Schalkern natürlich sagen.
Ja, also das lasse ich mir doch nicht nehmen. Mein One-Click-Away-Game sagt, soweit ich runter scrollen kann, hat Schalke zwei Mal vier Tore geschossen, in Elbersberg und in Paderborn. Das ist doch lustig.
Ausgerechnet gegen Elbersberg.
Und zwei Mal drei.
Vielleicht wollten sie ja in neuer Freundschaft dem FC einen Gefallen tun, um in neuer Freundschaft. Torverhältnis. Da nimmt sich jemand was raus.
Der FC Schalke hat auch zwei Mal drei Tore in der Saison geschossen. Zwei Mal gegen FÜD mindestens. Bei einem 3 zu 4 zu Hause.
Boah, stimmt.
Und bei einem 3 zu 3 in FÜD sehr schmerzhaft. Da kann man glaube ich auch überleiten, weil das wäre das Spiel gewesen, mit dem FÜD wahrscheinlich den Liga-Verbleib gesichert hätte. Und dann hat Silla in der, ich glaube, gefühlt 98. Minute das 3-3 noch gemacht. Also 2 x 3, 2 x 4, also der FC Schalke. Ich weiß gar nicht, was ihr alle habt. Eine super Mannschaft.
Das ist wirklich Wahnsinn. Nee, dann lass uns doch gerne über die Spielvereinigung Greuther FÜRD reden. Das Kleeblatt holte am 33. Spieltag einen Punkt in Hannover und steht somit einen Zeh da vor Platz 15 und Platz 16. Es sind jetzt schon neun Spiele bei FÜRD ohne Sieg. Und was Anfang dann vergangener Woche dazu führte, dass Trainer Jan Sievert den Job verlor nach Alexander Zorniger, der bereits 2. Trainer, der in FÜRD diese Saison entlassen wird. Michi, was um Himmelswein ist eigentlich in FÜRD diese Saison los? Also wo liegen diese Gründe für diese wirklich extrem miese Saison, die ja auch Rashid Azusi, dem langjährigen Sportchef, im Oktober 2024 den Job kosteten?
Ich muss dich ganz kurz noch berichtigen, es waren sogar drei Trainer schon. Also es ist Duo jetzt Thomas Kleine und Milorad Pekovic, das ist sogar das vierte Trainer-Duo schon. Es gab auch noch Leo Haas zwischendurch.
Oh Gott, stimmt.
Der hat auch noch vier Spiele inklusive Pokal gemacht und es wurde ihm eigentlich zugesagt, nach der Entlassung von Zornigga bis zum Winter der Trainer zu bleiben. Mit seinem Assistenten Julian Kolbeck wurde aber eben dann nicht zugestanden. Nach vier Spielen wurden sie dann doch entlassen. Sie wurden zurück zu U23 geschickt. Muss jetzt wieder sehr gute Arbeit machen. Ja, aber es wurde auch hinterher dann als Wortklauberei bezeichnet vom Geschäftsführer Holger Schwierwagner, dass man diese Formulierung bis zum Winter danach skeptisch gesehen hat. Man hätte ja auch sagen können, bis auf Weiteres und hätte sich alle Diskussionen entledigt. Aber gut, du hast gefragt, wie es dazu kam.
Puh, puh.
Also ich glaube, da bräuchten wir jetzt noch mal die eineinhalb Stunden. Die werden wir jetzt schon aufnehmen dafür. Deswegen versuche ich mich kurz zu fassen. Ganz allgemein kann man sagen, das wird in einer extrem entscheidenden und kritischen Phase sein als Gesamtverhalten. Also sowohl jetzt gerade in dieser Saison, also es kann auch sein, dass man auf dem Relegationsplatz abrutscht. Ist auch gar nicht mal so unwahrscheinlich, wenn man die Konstellation im Tabellenkeller sieht, weil Führts spielt gegen den HSV. Wir haben gerade schon zu wenige gesprochen. Eintracht Braunschweig gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg, der auch jetzt nicht die Top-Form hat und die Eintracht schon besser in Form als Führth auf jeden Fall. Ja, und Preußen Münster kommen wahrscheinlich auch noch drauf, ist auch noch gut in Form und kann vielleicht beim abgestiegenen SSV Ulm auch gewinnen. Und dann könnte es schnell sein, dass Führth auf Platz 16 noch rutscht und das halt passiert, was manchen Absteigern passiert, dass man halt einfach die ganze Zone eigentlich denkt, man steigt nicht ab und dann trotzdem auf Platz 16 landet. Ganz kurze Recap nur, also wir hatten es vorhin schon mal beim Scouting, Führth war jahrelang dafür bekannt, viele Spieler, junge Spieler zu holen, auch aus unteren Ligen oder jetzt zuletzt auch viele Leihspieler. Also man hatte ja Lampel und Urbik vom FC Köln, man hatte ja Robert Wagner vom SC Freiburg, der jetzt beim FC St. Pauli, naja spielt, ist falsch, aber dem FC St. Pauli zumindest der Bundesliga dabei ist und ab und zu mal eingewechselt wird. Und das waren drei sehr wichtige Spiele. Das waren auch drei potenzielle Unterschiedsspieler in dieser Liga.
Da sind wir wieder. Das ist der rote Faden dieser Sendung.
Genau. Und die sind ja alle gegangen. Dazu ging auch noch Amindou Sieb als Top-Tourjäger. Zuerst zum FC Bayern zurück und dann zum FSV Mainz 05. Und dann hat Raschita Susi im Sommer verkündet, dass man seine Transferstrategie etwas überdenkt. Und es hieß, man will diese jungen Spieler nicht mehr leihen, weil sie dann immer nach einem Jahr wieder weg sein, sondern man will die früher verpflichten und selbst entwickeln, hat man gemacht. Und dann mit Mathi Wagner vom 1. FC Köln und auch mit Reno Münz von Bayer Leverkusen. Ging jetzt dem Falle Mathi Wagner nicht allzu gut. Da hat man schon in der Sommerpause gesehen, dass so ein halbes Jahr zweite Mannschaft im FC, in der Regionalliga West nicht unbedingt reicht, um in der 2. Liga zu spielen. Mittlerweile ist er zu Rot-Weiß Essen ausgeliehen im Winter und spielt da auch nicht wirklich regelmäßig und wird wahrscheinlich da auch bleiben, wenn es in der 2. Liga ist. Insofern war die Transferstrategie nicht ganz so, ja, so erfolgsversprechend im Sommer. Man hat auch verpasst, Schlüsselpositionen zu besetzen, auch zu wiederholten Male. Das ist auch einer der Gründe, warum Asusi gehen musste, meiner Meinung nach. Also man hat seit dem Abgang von Max Christiansen nach Hannover vor zwei Jahren keinen ligatauglichen Sechser verpflichtet. Also man hatte in der vergangenen Saison Orestis Kiumozoglu, die Kenner werden es wissen, verpflichtet.
Das ist doch der Nürnberger Sportdirektor, oder?
Hallo, der ist Joti Khatzi Alexiou, wie ich gelernt habe bei den Kollegen von Kadeb. Ja, aber Orestis Kiumozoglu ist mit allem beim SVW in Wiesbaden, der dritten Liga, aber spielt da auch nicht regelmäßig. Insofern, das war der Königstransfer der letzten Saison. Da hatte man dann Glück, das war Robert Wagner, das eben eingenommen hat, der eigentlich als Achter kam. Dieses Sechs, jetzt im Sommer hat man wieder sehr lange gesucht, obwohl man ja eigentlich wusste, dass man diesen Sechser braucht, hat dann Ende August jemand verpflichtet mit Sacha Boncey von Stadter Lüttich für 200.000 Euro, der jetzt aber auch im Winter spätestens seinen Standplatz verloren hat. Also auch da wieder kein Sechser da. Man hat dann den Außenverteidiger Marco Maier probiert, mal insgesamt vier oder fünf Spiele probiert und das ist natürlich schon krass, wenn man einfach keinen Sechser hat. Die Innenverteidigung hat man sträflich vernachlässigt, sieht man an den Daten, also sowohl an den reinen Gegentoren als auch zwischenzeitlich mal an den Expected Goals Against. Man hatte über zwei dazwischenzeitlich. Alexander Zorniger hat mich immer kritisiert, wenn ich auf die Expected Goals Against eingehen. Er sagte, mir Hänse ja nicht kassiert. Irgendwann Hänse sie ja doch kassiert. Für das hatte er dann zeitweise die zweitschrittliche Defensive der Liga. Ja, das hat Alexander Zorniger dann den Job gekostet, relativ früher schon. Nach dem 0-4 im Derby, auch das einer dieser Momente der Saison, 0-4 im Derby zu verlieren mit einer katastrophalen Leistung. Es gab dann noch mal ein weiteres Derby mit 0-3, was eine ebenfalls katastrophale Leistung war, wo man sich nach dem 0-3 zur Pause ergeben hat. Das wurde dann auch relativ deutlich gesagt. Man wollte einfach kein weiteres Tor mehr kassieren. Ob das richtige Rangehensweis ist, wenn die Stimmung schon aufgeheizt ist und man sagt, man ergibt sich dem Kontrahenten im Derby und ist dann glücklich und sagt hinterher sogar, das war ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung, weil wir haben ja kein Tor mehr kassiert. Das hat alles dazu geführt, dass die Stimmung auch in Fürth eine sehr angespannte ist. Dazu kommt auch, dass man den Fürth einen Trainer hat. Und dass man auch in Fürth jahrelang stand dafür, dass man schön Fußball spielt. Der Fürther Flachpass mit Stefan Leitl, das wissen viele noch im Aufstiegsjahr. Das war ein wunderbar anzusehen, der Fußball. Klar, mit einer Mannschaft, mit Spielern, die jetzt auch ganz woanders spielen. Also Anton Stach als Sechser spielt in der Bundesliga, David Rauhm als Linksverteidiger spielt in der Bundesliga. Aber es gibt auch Spieler, die damals schon da waren. Und das bringt mich zum weiteren Punkt, dass ich glaube, dass so langsam so ein Zyklus, auch erfolgreicher Zyklus in Fürth zu Ende geht. Also bei Maradona Maregota kam 2019, Trini Green kam schon 2017, Marco Mayhoever als Rechtsverteidiger kam 2019. Die sind immer noch da. Deswegen dürfte man mit einer Mannschaft, mit diesem Namen nicht auf Platz 16 möglich stehen, in dieser Liga noch dazu, weil ja viele Mannschaften ähnlich schlecht performen. Aber vielleicht sind auch manche Spieler langsam in einem Alter, in dem sich ihre Top-Leistung nicht mehr über 34 oder 30 Spiele abrufen können, sondern nur über 15 bis 20. Und das sind wir wieder bei Jan Lukas Punkt. Unterschiedsspieler, also Brani Maregota und Trini Green, sind potenziell unterschiedsspiel in der 2. Liga. Das betont, gefühlt jeder Trainer oder hat jeder Trainer, gefühlt betont, weil in den letzten Monaten sind sie es eben nicht mehr. Also Brani Maregota fand ich in den letzten 3, 4 Wochen mit den schlechtesten Spieler bei der Spielvereinigung. Und Julian Green hat auch jetzt nur 2 Tore gemacht. Er schießt mittlerweile die Elfmeter, deswegen hat er 7. Sieht schön aus nach Statistik. Brani Maregota hat nur 6. Er hat eigentlich immer, seit er da ist, entführt. Ich brauche nicht alle Daten runterzuleiern, aber er hat in jeder Saison zweistätig getroffen. Sogar in der Bundesliga hat er 9 Mal getroffen. Und jetzt hat er halt nur 6 Tore. Und das ist auch eine tragische Geschichte dieser Saison, denn er hat mit seinem Tor in Düsseldorf am 28. Februar, das war auch der letzte Sieg der Spielvereinigung, da sieht man, wie lang der schon her ist, da hat er ein 54. Zweitliga-Tor geschossen und ist dabei der Rekord-Torschütze, aber zusammen wird jemandem aus den 70ern. Und ihm fehlt noch ein Tor, um der alleinige Zweitliga-Rekord-Torschütze dieses Vereins zu werden. Und natürlich schießt er seit dem seit 9 Spielen kein Tor mehr. Und es kann halt gut sein, dass er im Sommer vielleicht sogar geht. Es gab da schon Gerüchte, dass Breni Mirkul sein Verein wirklich verlassen könnte. Sein Vertrag läuft noch eine Saison, auch von Julian Green läuft noch eine Saison. Marco Mayer hatte ich angesprochen, läuft auch nur noch eine Saison, nee, läuft jetzt aus. Genau, ist ordentlich verlängert. Man geht davon aus, dass er geht. Es laufen auch weitere Verträge aus. Gied und Jung zum Beispiel, auch ein Spiel, der jetzt schon länger da ist. Insofern glaube ich, dass so ein Zyklus zu Ende geht. Man hat es auch schon mehrmals postuliert, dass man einen Neuaufbau, einen Neuanfang starten möchte. Es ist aber unabdingbar, dass man in der Liga 2 startet, weil Fürth ein Standort ist, der so dringend auf TV-Gelder angewiesen ist und jetzt gerade auch in einer kritischen Phase ist, weil man halt einfach noch zwei Trainer bezahlt. Einer ist zumindest abgefunden mit Zornigge, aber man bezahlt jetzt Sievert noch weiter, der Vertrag bis 26 hat, man bezahlt Assusi weiter bis 26. Das sind Kosten für einen Verein, der eh nicht so auf großen gebettet ist, der jetzt auch keine Transferennahmen haben wird, weil man halt einfach keine Spiele hat, die herausstechen. Und es gab Gerüchte, dass Brandy Mercotra für einen Score von 5 Millionen gehen könnte. Vielleicht muss man ihn vielleicht verkaufen, um das Geld einzunehmen. Ich bin nur gespannt, ob jemand das Geld hinlegt. Und es gäbe noch viele weitere Themen, dass der Verein einfach in einer extrem kritischen Phase ist. Man hat vor einigen Wochen das Projekt einer neuen Gegend gerade vorgestellt. Die möchte man umbauen für, korrekt, um die 35 Millionen. Und die Schwiegfang muss ja das selber auftreiben, das Geld, weil sie kein städtisches Stadion hat, keine Zuschüsse bekommt. Zumindest keine in der Höhe, wie sie andere Vereine bekommen. Ein anderes Thema ist noch das Thema Vereinsnahme des Schwäls seit vielen Jahren. Und Schwiegfang gehört dafür, dass du vorhin gesagt hast, die Fans wollen oder viele Fans wollen Schwiegfang wird vor der Rückbenennung. Also da gibt es so viele Themen und dann halt auch diese sportliche Krise dazu, dass man einfach momentan, also ich, man könnte stundenlang über diesen Verein reden. Ich verweise auf den 4. Flachpass, da kann man das auch nachhören. Und ja, Lukas hatte gerade noch eine Frage gestellt, was mit Simon Astor ist. Simon Astor ist auch ja schon länger da, kam glaube ich 2020, will ich mir an. Er war der Backup von May für eine Aufstiegssaison, als er in die Bundesliga aufgestiegen ist. Sein Vertrag läuft auch aus, er wird auch gehen. Also da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, ich glaube, dass wird keinen auslaufenden Vertrag mehr verlängern wird. Man hat nur einen verlängert, nämlich mit Luca Itter, der auch der deutlich stabilste Innenverteidiger der Saison jetzt auch ist, über 34 Spiele hinweg, oder 30, die er wahrscheinlich gemacht hat. Simon Astor wurde zumindest laut einem Gerücht mit der SV Elversberg in Verbindung gebracht, was insofern ja logisch erscheint, weil Elias Baum da ja geht, zurück zu Eintracht Frankfurt. Aber Simon Astor hat auch eine gar nicht mal so gute Runde gespielt. Und ich wurde schon mal dafür kritisiert, dass ich Alexander Zornigert zu oft zitiere, aber er hat halt einfach doch Spuren hinterlassen. Und er hat mal gesagt, der Simon muss auch mal Zahlen liefern. Und als offensiver Schiedensspieler in einem 3-4-1-2 kommt mir ab und zu auch mal eine Abschlussposition. Und er hat halt keinen Tor und keine Vorlage in der ganzen Saison. Ist jetzt auch keine herausragende Bilanz.
Aber er wird bei Elversberg bei 4 Toren und 12 Vorlagen rauskommen. Ja, also bin ich mir auch sicher.
Genau, also Lukas Petkoff hat in Fürth auch keine allzu glückliche Figur abgegeben und ist jetzt der Stammspieler beim Tabellen-3. der 2. Liga. Insofern gibt es so Umfelder, in denen man anscheinend besser blühen kann als in Fürth. Ja, aber wie gesagt, ja, ne, frag nur. Ich komm nur in den Redefluss, wenn ich über diesen Verein spreche.
Ne, alles gut. Aber ich wollte eher so einen Zwischenfazit ziehen. Also ich höre raus, es ist einfach wirklich eine negative Eigendynamik, die sich angenommen hat, aufgrund einer fehlerhaften Kaderplanung, aufgrund von Zyklen, die vielleicht auch enden. Das kennt, glaube ich, jeder Verein, dass es manchmal diese Spielegenerationen gibt, die dann auch irgendwann einfach fertig haben. Und dass deswegen auch kein Trainerwechsel wirklich nachhaltig gefruchtet hat, weil der Boden ein sehr wackeliger gerade in Fürth einfach im Allgemeinen ist. Und das spürt man ja auch daran. Ich habe mir von einem Fürther-Fan auch erzählen lassen, dass mittlerweile das Bannen zwischen Mannschaft und Fans auch vollkommen zerschnitten ist. Also, dass die Mannschaft teilweise gar nicht mehr in die Kurve kommt, weil die wissen, da kommt eh nichts Gutes und niemand erwartet mehr gegenseitig von sich was. Und alle sind froh, wenn das im Sommer einfach endet.
Das ist ja nochmal sehr gefährlich. Also, wenn man die anderen Vereine anschaut, die im Tabellenkeller stehen. Also bei Ulm hat man es ganz exemplarisch gesehen, als hier in Fürth gespielt haben. Vor einigen Wochen ist die ganze Mannschaft nochmal zum Gästeblog vor diesem großen, was man kennt, wir geben nie auf Banner. Und in Fürth gab es zumindest nach diesem Derby, nach dieser zweiten Derby-Niederlage im März, also im Spiel danach, ein großes Derby-Versager-Banner in der Heimkurve. Und da wurde der Mannschaft auch sowohl auf dem Banner als auch dann über die Mikrofonanlage der Ultras quasi die Zustimmung entzogen. Und es gibt einfach keinen Gemeinsamen mehr in diesem Sinne. Und das führte dazu, dass es mehrmals auch Beleidigungen offenbar gab und Bittelfingen in Richtung der Mannschaft. Und sie wurde auch immer öfter mal weggeschickt. Also es gehört auch dazu, dass Furt hat vor diesem Spiel in Hannover am Wochenende vier Auswärtsspieler in Folge zu Null verloren hat, was auch nicht allzu schön ist als Auswärtsfan, der sich stundenlang in den Bus oder Zug oder ins Auto setzt. Und dann gab es eben diesen Eklat von dir angesprochen, dass die Mannschaft beim Spiel gegen den 1. FC Köln 1 zu 1 war eigentlich ein OK-Auftritt von Furt. Und die Ultras haben wie angekündigt zusammengepackt und haben gesagt, okay, wir supporten die Mannschaft während des Spiels. Aber es gibt kein weder Schimpfen noch Applaus noch irgendwas. Wir gehen einfach nach dem Spiel. Und aber Teile der Tribüne haben geklatscht nach diesem Spiel. Und die Mannschaft hat sich demonstrativ in Richtung der Gegend gerade bewegt und dann demonstrativ 180 Grad gedreht und Richtung Haupttribüne. Ja, ist kurz gelaufen, hat abprojektiert und ist gegangen. Und man hat es dann öffentlich nicht zugegeben als Mannschaft, was ich auch komisch fand. Also es hieß, wir haben ja nicht gewonnen, deswegen sind wir nicht zur Kurve gegangen. Man könnte ja auch sagen, wir wollten nicht aufgrund der Beleidigung in den letzten Wochen. Auch das sowas. Also mir fehlt da so auch in der Mannschaft ein bisschen jemand, der so das Sprachrohr nach außen ist. Vielleicht auch bei der künftigen Kaderplanung mal wieder brücksichtigen kann. Ja und dann wurde von Nico Giesemann auch einer der erfahrenen Spieler, deren Zyklus wahrscheinlich ausläuft, jetzt dann mal gesagt, wir waren nicht zufrieden damit, wie wir quasi von den Fans behandelt wurden. Und jetzt in Berlin ist es nochmal völlig eskaliert. Du hast den Graben vorhin angesprochen. Also das war gut, dass dieser Graben da im Olympiastadion da war, weil die Mannschaft dann offensichtlich, obwohl die Fans sie weggeschickt haben, zumindest die aktiven Fans sind, die Mannschaft ist in die Kurve gegangen und hat den Austausch gesucht und das war sehr hektisch. Es wurde sich sehr gestenreich und sehr laut angebrüllt. Man ist da aber im Guten auseinandergegangen und die Mannschaft hat jetzt auch am vergangenen Wochenende knapp 500 Fans die Reise nach Hannover bezahlt. Oder zumindest der Verein, aber offenbar auch zum guten Teil die Mannschaft aus der Mannschaftskasse und alle 1000 mitgereisten Fans auch die Eintrittskarten. Also es war ein Schritt aufeinander zu. Aber ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das jetzt am letzten Spieltag wird, weil bei Preußen Münster gibt es diesen Zusammenhalt, dieses Bann zwischen Fans und Mannschaft. Und das gibt es auch bei Eintracht Braunschweig. Wir haben diese Bilder wahrscheinlich alle gesehen, wie der Vorsänger vor einigen Wochen da auf dem Platz diese Ansprache gehalten hat. Danach hat die Mannschaft, glaube ich, zehn Punkte oder so geholt. Sie haben zumindest beim HSV gewonnen, haben gegen Paderborn gewonnen und sind jetzt halt auch in der glücklichen Lage, gegen den SFZ Nürnberg zu Hause zu spielen. Insofern gibt es da viele Dinge, die gegen die Spielfeindlichen sprechen. Aber Jan Lukas möchte was sagen.
Ich finde das extrem spannend, deine Ausführungen. Ich erkenne da leider extrem oft Kölner-Verhältnisse drin, von wegen Ergebnisse nach außen verkaufen und dann im Gegenzug Anspruchshaltung kritisieren plus, aber sportlich total unbesetzt und teilweise inkonstant. Ich fand das total spannend mit dem Zyklus, den du beschrieben hast. Deswegen hatte ich eben auch noch Asta gefragt, weil der bei mir noch so als U21-Nationalspieler irgendwie immer beschirmt war, aber irgendwie auch da kam nichts draußen. Tore Gota ja sowieso, wo man denkt, was für ein Wahnsinnsspieler eigentlich. Wo du es jetzt aber auch das so gut geschildert hast mit dem Zusammenhalt, Fans und Mannschaft, ist mir auch aufgefallen, dass ich, wie gesagt, ich schaue wirklich viel Zweite Liga, dass ich die führten Fans extrem oft als optisch, aber oder gerade optisch, aber auch lautstärk technisch als wirklich stark und Bereicherung für die Liga empfinde, obwohl das ja jetzt man das nicht unbedingt so vielleicht auf dem Schirm hat. Und ich finde, das überrascht mich das so ein bisschen, dass es, dass es irgendwie ja nicht so eine Einheit gibt, weil ich hatte es eigentlich aus Zuschauerperspektive gedacht. Ja, da kommen so viele mit und die geben schon auch irgendwie mal alles und unterstützen viel. Deswegen war das irgendwie, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich direkt eine Frage habe, aber ich finde, das klingt extrem, extrem toxisch so und brandgefährlich. Also das und ich hatte das jetzt auf dem Schirm, ich habe ja vorhin gesagt, ich dachte, führt wer durch, weil ich nur bis zur 80. gegen Hannover geguckt habe. Und ein Sieg da hätte ja im Prinzip schon gereicht. Und jetzt denke ich mir, ein Glück für Führt, dass es nur noch ein Spieltag ist. Das würdest du wahrscheinlich dann auch so sehen, oder?
Natürlich. Also Marc hat es angesprochen, es hat neun Spiele ohne Sieg. 28. Februar war das der letzte Sieg in Düsseldorf. Also auch das, da war die Fortuna auch gar nicht gut. Da wurde gepifft mit dem Stadion. Auch das ist ein Zeichen, dass die Fortuna vielleicht jetzt kein Aufstiegskandidat in dieser Saison ist, wenn man gegen Führt auswärts verliert. Und das passt ja auch dazu. Also man hatte diesen sehr erfolgreichen Februar, da war man nämlich die beste Mannschaft der 2. Liga im Februar. Blöderweise kam man dann zwei Monate, in denen man die schlechteste Mannschaft der 2. Liga war. Aber ohne diese Punkte, die man da im Februar geholt hat, unter anderem mit Auswärtssiegenden in Paderborn und in Düsseldorf, was ja sehr überraschend war, was aber auch zeigt, welches Potenzial eigentlich in dieser Mannschaft steckt, wenn es sich denn entfalten kann. Und dass eine Mannschaft mit Hurgotha Green, auch Felix Klaus hast du angesprochen, der hat in den ersten sechs Spielen fünf Vorlagen geliefert. Jetzt in den letzten Wochen aber leider sehr oft eine sehr unglückliche Figur abgegeben. Jetzt auch in Düsseldorf wieder mehrere klare große Chancen vergeben. Auch beim Hamscheg gegen Schalke war er zweimal alleine vorm Tor und hat vergeben. Also wenn der einfach ein, zwei Tore gemacht hätte, klar, er war noch nie dieser große Knipser der zweiten Liga, aber dann wäre man schon längst durch. Und das wäre ja, also es wäre im Bereich des Möglichen gewesen, als Fürth locker durch zu sein schon. Wie schon gesagt, eine Liga der verpassten Chancen. Ja, und zu diesem toxischen, zu diesem nicht vorhandenen Band zwischen Fans und Mannschaft, das führt natürlich ganz klar zurück auf dieses Derby. Also das Hinspiel-Derby war für Fürth ein Schock. Man hat 0 zu 4 gegen Nürnberg zu Hause verloren. Das hatte man einfach über viele Jahrzehnte einfach nicht getan. Man war ja immer dieser Underdog im Derby und hat diese Derbys aber trotzdem immer sehr gut bestritten und dann zu Hause 0 zu 4 zu verlieren, chancenlos, um sich quasi fast schon zu ergeben. Das war wirklich hart. Da gab es zum ersten Mal, wie man sie kennt, Ansprache der Vorsänger gegenüber der Mannschaft auf dem Platz. Und dann gab es natürlich dieses Rückspiel-Derby. Das war nochmal genauso. Und für die Fürther Seele, wenn man es auch ein bisschen so soziologisch sieht, fürht es immer dieser kleine Nachbar von Nürnberg wird auch gerne als zu klein gehalten. Es gab früher Versuche von Nürnberg, fürth einzugemeinden. Insofern sind diese Nachbarschaftsvergleiche sehr, sehr wichtig und sehr prestigeträchtig. Und wenn man dann als Kleines führt, dass es gegen das große Nürnberg oft gut mitgehalten hat, dass in den letzten fünf Jahren immer vor dem 1. FC Nürnberg standen. In der Tabelle gut lag auch mal dran, dass der 1. FC Nürnberg mal 16. wurde und man selbst 12. Also insofern so erfolgreich war es nicht immer, aber man war immer vor dem 1. FC Nürnberg. Und dass man dann zweimal dieses Spiel mit 0 zu 7 verliert, kein Tor im Derby schießt, auch möglich 0 zu 8 oder 0 zu 9 hätte als Bilanz haben können, das hat ganz tiefe Gräben hinterlassen. Und es gab halt auch noch andere Spiele. Ich habe im Vorgespräch erwähnt, der Fürth gegen Darmstadt zu Hause 1-5 verloren, 0-5 am HSV verloren, 4-2 gegen Kaislautern zu Hause verloren. Es gab einfach zu viele Spiele, in denen die Mannschaft ihr Potenzial gar nicht auf den Platz gebracht hat. Ich kann mir das auch gar nicht erklären, woran das liegt, weil die Spieler das eigentlich können. Es gab viele Spiele, die sind dann gekippt oder unglücklich gekippt. Man hat das Spiel in Darmstadt und Karlsruhe in den letzten Wochen, da hätte man locker einen Punkt holen können. Wenn man diese ein, zwei Punkte geholt hätte, wäre man jetzt, wie Jan Lukas sagte, längst schon durch. Jetzt hat man die blöde Situation gegen die stärkste Mannschaft der 2. Liga vielleicht gewinnen zu müssen. Oder, wie ich es mir schon eingerichtet habe, zu Pille Wollitz fahren zu müssen nach Cottbus. Das wäre gar nicht so schön.
Nein, das wäre nicht schön. Wobei der Stadion der Freundschaft ist tatsächlich ganz nett, kann ich sagen aus eigener Erfahrung. Aber es ist dann natürlich noch mal eine andere Situation. Ich hatte eigentlich die Frage in meiner Vorbereitung formuliert, wie es denn jetzt in Fürth im Sommer weitergeht und wie groß der Umbruch sein wird. Nach deiner Ausführung würde ich einfach das unter die Überschrift schreiben, alles neu.
Ich bitte deswegen auch diese Formulierung der ganz entscheidenden Phase hinter der Verein. Man braucht halt wieder eine Identität. Also dieser Verein hatte jahrelang eine fußballerische Identität. Man hatte eine im Scouting. Und der Verein ist gerade auf der Suche noch seine Identität. Deswegen wäre es ja sehr wichtig, einen Trainer zu haben, der eine klare Philosophie und eine klare Identität hat, wie es damals Stefan Leitl hatte.
Oder Alexander Zorniger hatte sie doch ein Stück weit auch, oder?
Ja, aber er hatte die RB-Pressing, wie auch immer, Alexander Zorniger-Fußball-Idee. Hatte aber den Kader nicht dazu. Letztes Jahr hatte man den mit Tim Lempeler. Jetzt hatte man diesen Stürmer halt nicht. Man hat gehofft, dass Nubel Furtkoi auch eine ähnliche Energie reinbringen kann. Aber da kam das der Regionalliga und hat auch ein bisschen gebraucht. Trotzdem mit 11 Toren der Torjäger dieser Mannschaft, der auch viele entscheidende Tore gemacht hat. Und man hatte halt so eine halbe Ballbesitzmannschaft, die aber eine Pressingmannschaft sein sollte. Insofern auch nicht allzu glücklich. Und auch, ja, das kann schön aussehen zu Pressingfußball, aber ich bin eher ein Fan, wie unser Podcast ja auch heißt, für der Flachpass ein Fan des schönen Spiels. Und das für das Publikum ist auch anspruchsvoll. Das will ich auch ein schönes Spiel sehen. Klar, will es vor allem Siege und Tore sehen, aber auch ein schönes Spiel. Und deswegen fände ich da einen Trainer, der wieder auf schön Fußball setzt, sehr, sehr wichtig. Und dann kann man den Kader auch danach ausrichten.
Christian Ziviel. Kennt sich in der Legion aus? Nein, nein, nein.
Ich habe ja vorhin schon mal einen Wunsch geäußert. Ein anderer Wunsch ist jetzt beim 1. FC Kaislautern schon Trainer. Insofern werden wir sehen, wohin das führt. Es gab zuletzt Gerüchte, dass der Trainer der SV Ried aus der 2. österreichischen Liga bei Fürth und Preußen Münster auf dem Titel stünde. Aber diese Gerüchte gibt es ja ständig insofern. Aber das wäre zumindest ein Trainer, der in Interviews schon über klare Philosophien gesprochen hat. Insofern habe ich da irgendwie Sympathie dafür.
Da hast du die Ohren gespitzt.
Natürlich, und die Augen. Aber klar, es hängt alles davon ab, dass man in dieser Liga bleibt. Wenn man in der 3. Liga ist, dann wird man einen ganz anderen Neuanfang starten müssen, nämlich einen radikalen wahrscheinlich. Und dann wird es auch extrem schwer. Es wurde mal in Fürth formuliert, bei 2 Jahre 3. Liga könnte man durchhalten finanziell. Dann würde es schon kritisch. Und das gibt es ja auch schon viele Vereine mit einer deutlich größeren Strahlkraft. Man muss nur mal nach Aachen schauen, die aufgestiegen sind. Und viele andere Vereine dieser Liga. Da wäre man auch nicht der klare Aufstiegsfavorit im 1. Jahr. Insofern ist dieser Abstieg unbedingt zu vermeiden. Er wäre auch schon längst zu vermeiden gewesen. Ich wiederhole mich. Leider hat man das in zu vielen Phasen verpasst. Aber wenn man aus den letzten 10 Spielen dann keines gewinnt, hat man es vielleicht auch ein bisschen verdient, in die Relegation zu rutschen.
Vielleicht sind das die sehr passenden Worte zu diesem Segment. Und zu diesem kleinen Viert-Schwerpunkt würde ich gar nicht sagen, nach der Zeit, die wir jetzt über den Verein geredet haben. Das hat schon viel abgedeckt. Aber ich weiß mich längst nicht alles. Aber wie gesagt, da verweisen wir auf den Viertelflachpass. Ich glaube, da kann man sich wirklich dann die volle Dosis dahingehend holen. Und wir werden es sehen. Der nächste Spieltag wird da sehr viel Klarheit bringen.
Ich möchte noch was Kleines anhängen. Wir sind ja im Rasenfunk. Da spricht man ja gerne über Daten. Fürze hat am 24. Spieltag nach dem 2-1 in Düsseldorf 10 Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz. Nach unten, unten und neun auf den nach oben. Also man war schon mal dem Aufstiegs-Relegationsplatz, über den wir auch schon ausführlich gesprochen haben, deutlich näher in der Saison. Wird der Weis-Herr-Appeil seitdem nur noch vier Punkte geholt. Jetzt hat man 36 statt 32.
Ja.
Tja, und wer 35 Punkte hat und dementsprechend ein Punkt weniger als Viert ist Preußen Münster, allerdings mit dem deutlich besseren Torverhältnis, würde also bei einem Unentschieden eine Rolle spielen. Die Münsteraner trennten sich vor zwei Spieltagen von außen überraschend von Trainer Sascha Hildmann. Es übernahm ein Trio rund um Christian Panda. Der Move zahlte sich bislang aus, muss man ja wirklich sagen. Es gab einen sensationellen 5 zu 0-Sieg gegen Magdeburg und am 33. Spieltag am letzten ein 2 zu 0-heimem Erfolg. Und auch der war verdient. Das kann ich nach 90 Minuten Betrachtung absolut sagen. Ein 2 zu 0-heimem Erfolg gegen Hertha BSC. Diese zwei Siege lassen Münster wieder ganz klar vom Klassenerhalt träumen. Und wie groß das Momentum des SCP ist, berichtet uns nun Carsten Schulte vom Online-Magazin Preußen-Journal.
Ja, was macht Preußen Münster? Also erstmal, es ist relativ überraschend, dass Preußen Münster überhaupt noch mal in der Lage ist, den Klassenerhalt aus eigener Kraft und direkt fertig zu machen. Das sah vor zwei Wochen noch ganz anders aus. Vor drei Wochen hat der SCP in Köln verloren, 1 zu 3. Da waren wir, das muss man ehrlich sagen, relativ chancenlos. Das 1 zu 1 danach gegen Darmstadt, das war auch so meh. Also irgendwie so richtig hatte man da nicht mehr den Glauben, dass das klappen könnte. Jetzt gibt es die unverbesserlichen Optimisten, die immer gesagt haben, natürlich wird das was. Aber realistisch war es schon so, dass das Momentum, wie man so schön sagt, ganz klar gegen Münster ausgeschlagen war. Wir waren runter auf den Abstiegsplatz, also direkten Abstiegsplatz. Ulmer hat uns überholt, Braunschweig war fünf Punkte weg. Das muss man sich mal überlegen. Und dann ist etwas passiert, was niemand geglaubt hat. Der SCP hat Sascha Hildmann rausgeworfen, den Doppelaufstiegstrainer seit fünfeinhalb Jahren hier an der Seitenlinie. Das war schon so ein kleiner Kulturschock. Aber wie das im Fußball so ist, auf einmal war das Momentum dann da, nur eben in die andere Richtung. Die Entlassung von Hildmann, die kam schon relativ überraschend. Aber jetzt hört man so, dass es da eine schon länger dauernde Entfremdung gegeben hat. Das ist jetzt keinesfalls so, dass die Mannschaft gegen den Trainer gespielt hat. Das war nur einfach zu merken, dass diese letzten Prozente Überzeugungen irgendwie gefehlt haben. Man muss sagen, mit dem Interimstrio, das der SCP jetzt installiert hat, da hat sich genau an der Stelle etwas verändert. Es gab gar nicht so viele Änderungen, so ein bisschen andere Positionen, auch ein bisschen überraschend. Aber ich will mal sagen, eine andere Grundhaltung, nämlich kompakte Defensive ja, aber eben auch offensiv deutlich lebendiger, deutlich engagierter. Das zeigt sich unter anderem daran, dass Jorrit Hendricks, der Sechser von Preußen Münster, plötzlich drei Tore schießt, weil er nach vorne hin mehr Freiheiten hat. Vorher war er so ein bisschen eingezwängt in dieses Defensivkorsett. Das zahlt sich jetzt plötzlich aus. Das ist übrigens auch etwas, was man grundsätzlich Sascha Hildmann schon noch zuschreiben darf, dass er die Abwehr der Preußen über die Saison so stabilisiert und gefestigt hat, dass wir jetzt mit einem Torverhältnis von minus 3 am besten dastehen von allen Klubs da unten. Und das bedeutet, am letzten Spieltag hat es der SCP im Grunde eine eigene Hand, ein Sieg in Ulm.
Und der Klassenerhalt ist geritzt. Wenn es rechnerisch passt, Führer darf nicht gewinnen, Schalke muss verlieren gegen Elhausberg. Wenn Münster in Ulm gewinnt, können die sogar noch 13er werden. Das muss man sich wirklich vorstellen. Aber Platz 15 würde hier auch jeder mit Handkuss nehmen. Es ist also immer noch ein Endspiel in Ulm, aber es ist ein anderes Endspiel als vorher gedacht. Für Ulm tut es mir persönlich total leid. Ich weiß, die sind im letzten Jahr mit uns parallel so voller Elan in die zweite Liga reingehüpft. Ich war beide lange nicht in der 2. Liga, Münster noch viel länger nicht als Ulm, aber es war halt schon einfach so ein völlig unerwarteter Sturmlauf und irgendwie ist es schon schade, dass zwei von den drei Aufsteigern direkt wieder runter müssen. Wie gesagt, gerade für Ulm finde ich es echt ein bisschen traurig. Ich bin mal gespannt, wie die sich präsentieren werden am Sonntag, aber naja, wird auf jeden Fall ein spannender, ein spannender letzter Spieltag, so aus Preußensicht, aber mit den Aussichten, dass mindestens die Relegation sicher ist, würde ich sagen, verbreitet das schon einigermaßen gute Laune. Und wenn ich mich festlegen müsste, würde ich einfach behaupten, dass Münster das Ding zieht und in der Liga bleibt.
Ich glaube, es gibt einen Grund gerade für diesen Optimismus, der ist ja fast schon Realismus nach den letzten beiden Spielen. Vorhin Preuß Münster, vielen lieben Dank, Carsten Schulter an der Stelle. Ja, Jan Lukas, wie gesagt, Münster gastiert am letzten Spieltag, mein bereits abgestiegener SSV Ulm. Reicht es also am Ende zum direkten Klassenhalt?
Ich habe während der Nachricht dreimal die Spiele, die Restspiele von allen angeschaut. Und das ist ja wirklich auch da so schwierig, vorherzusagen. Ja, die Mannschaft wirkt wirklich entfesselt so. Das ist auch das, was sogar bis nach Köln irgendwie ein bisschen durchgedrungen ist, dass die Mannschaft und Sascha Hildmann eben irgendwie ein bisschen sich verloren haben. Und ja, dann wurde sehr gut beschrieben, dass da jetzt eben, ja, also ich meine, man muss ja nur sagen, 5-0 gegen Magdeburg. Und das ist natürlich ein totaler Schwung jetzt. Und trotzdem ist Ullm jetzt abgestiegen, spielt zu Hause. Und das hat man auch schon so oft gesehen, dass eine Mannschaft sich dann irgendwie nochmal gut verabschieden will. Es geht um nichts mehr. Dann kann man plötzlich irgendwie doch befreit aufspielen. Also von der Ausgangslage her spricht alles für Münster. Ich finde, es spricht nur fast so viel für Münster, dass ich es fast wieder ein bisschen gruselig finde.
So.
Und trotzdem würde ich es ihnen auf jeden Fall gönnen. So, das muss man sagen. Ich finde, es ist eine Mannschaft, die ja, die hat irgendwie einen Charakter. Die haben auch sehr unglückliche Spiele gehabt. Aber das betrifft alle da unten. Über Ulm haben wir ja schon gesprochen. Braunschweig dagegen, kommen wir ja gleich zu, hat sich irgendwie total zwischenzeitlich aufgerafft. Also ich finde es so schwer, wenn man jetzt direkt das Restprogramm aufmacht mit Braunschweig gegen Nürnberg, dass es dann wieder verführt, ein bisschen spannend, dass Braunschweig theoretisch Schützenhilfe von Nürnberg bekommen könnte. Also ich finde es wahnsinnig schwer. Also die Frage bleibt Münze in der Liga. Irgendwie sagt mein Gefühl, dass es zu wahrscheinlich ist, als dass es passieren würde. Aber ich halte es eben schon auch für wahrscheinlich.
Ja, es ist total fair. Also Fußball herrscht ja auch immer, aber ich glaube, man darf sich der Sache nicht zu sicher sein. Das ist schon so. Michi, hast du noch was zum SCP beizutragen, oder wollen wir zum punktgleichen Rivalen?
In Anbetracht der Zeit können wir, glaube ich, zum punktgleichen Rivalen. Ich möchte das auch wieder da. Eine so, was wäre wenn-Geschichte. Fird hat in Münster am ersten Spieltag der Rückrunde gespielt, stand 1 zu 1, bis in die Nachspielzeit. Dann gab es ein sehr dummes Foul und einen letzten Freistaat für Preußen Münster, eine Flanke, ein Kopfball von Joshua Mees, mit der, glaube ich, 1,80 groß ist, und 2 zu 1 für Preußen Münster. Also auch da, wenn Fird einfach ein Foul weniger gemacht hätte, auch da wäre der Klassenheil schon safe und Preußen Münster würde sich vielleicht freuen, noch in der Relegation spielen zu können. Ja, aber eine Liga der verpassten Chancen, wir wiederholen uns.
Ja, das ist fast die Überschrift dieser Sendung. Punktgleich mit Münster steht Eintracht Braunschweig aufgrund des deutlich schlechteren Torverhältnisses auf dem Relegationsrang. Die Braunschweiger stiegen ja nach der 1.5-Klatsche gegen Hertha am 26. Spieltag wieder. Der Phoenix aus der Asche hielten an Trainer Daniel Scherning fest und blieben sechs Spiele lang ungeschlagen, inklusive drei Siegen gegen Paderborn, den HSV und Lautern, also auch nicht gegen irgendwen. Seit drei Spielen ist die Luft aber so ein bisschen raus. Nur zwei Punkte und zuletzt eine 0-3-Pleite gegen Elbersberg. Das ist eine ganz schöne emotionale Achterbahnfahrt, von der berichtet uns nun Anna Lautenbach vom Podcast gegen gerade.
Hallo lieber Rasenfunk und vielen, vielen Dank, dass ich Teil dieser Sendung sein darf. Mitten im Saison-Einsport kurz vor dem allerletzten Spieltag, dem Showdown und dem Herzschlag-Finale, das die Braunschweiger Eintracht gegen den Club aus Nürnberg bestreiten wird. Wir sind alle maximal angespannt, denn die Forderung ist ganz klar, wir brauchen drei Punkte, so gut die letzten Wochen für uns gelaufen sind in der großen Summe und der Bilanz, die uns, glaube ich, so niemals zugetraut hätte, mit diesem furiosen 4 zu 2 auswärts beim jetzt aufgestiegenen HSV. Wir haben Paderborn geschlagen, wir haben jetzt auch zuletzt einen durchaus ordentlichen Auftritt gegen Düsseldorf zu Hause hingelegt, den wir mit einem 2-2 beendet haben. Einige Stimmen sagen, wir hätten das gewinnen müssen. Die Punkte dieser zwei zusätzlichen hätten uns aktuell sicherlich sehr, sehr gut getan. So sind wir in der Situation vom Relegationsplatz aktuell in den sicheren Hafenklassen. Wir fahren viel mehr, schwimmen wahrscheinlich zu wollen. Dafür brauchen wir meiner Meinung nach drei Punkte. Das wird schwierig gegen einen launischen Club, dem ich genauso viel zutraue wie meiner Eintracht. Ich hoffe, dass uns diese drei Punkte retten werden, so wir sie denn einfahren. Denn klar ist auch, sollten Fürth und Münster ihre Spiele gewinnen. Hilft uns das alles nichts, dann müssen wir in die Relegation. Das würde ich sehr gerne vermeiden. Deshalb alle Kräfte bündeln. Ich traue es dem Team zu. Es ist fit. Es ist insgesamt konzentriert, würde ich sagen. Und insgesamt weniger wankelmütig als über lange Phasen der Saison. Jetzt aber natürlich auswärts 3-0, Gott sei Dank nur 3-0 in Elbersberg. Natürlich gegen ein sehr spielstarkes Team, aber nichtsdestotrotz dieses ungeliebte Gesicht mal wieder gezeigt. Ja, gilt es zu vergessen und den Fokus jetzt auf den Heimsieg zu legen, damit so der hoffentlich blau-gelbe Fußgabend bei Gott möchte, ich auch nächstes Jahr bei der Ligatour 2. Liga Rasenfunk dabei sein darf. So mein Verein. Denn die Klasse hält. Das wäre wirklich toll. Ich freue mich über jeden gedrückten Daumen. Ich danke für die Einladung und wünsche euch noch ganz viel Spaß. Tschüss, tschüss.
Ja, tschau, tschau. Es ist richtig. Es geht hier auch um viel. Es geht hier nicht um den Klassenhalt, sondern auch um ein Verbleiben im Rasenfunk. Denn der deckt noch nicht die dritte Liga ab. Da hängt viel dran. Auch viel Sichtbarkeit für die Vereine. Nein, aber nach den Ausführungen würde ich auch hier– beziehungsweise, lasst uns gerne noch mal kurz über Braunschweig reden, weil ich das schon– ich finde es sehr honorig, wie sie nach dem 1 zu 5– ich habe das ja 90 Minuten gesehen gegen Hertha– das war wirklich katastrophal, wie sie sich da präsentiert haben. Und gefühlt hat Daniel Scherning– der wurde auf der PK von den Journalisten angezählt und hat schon diese typischen Fragen bekommen– ist dann nicht die Amtszeit eines Trainers mehr oder weniger beendet nach so einem Spiel und so und hat sich gefühlt nicht mal mehr gewehrt und sie halten an ihm fest und hauen dann so eine Serie heraus– das hätte ich nicht geglaubt. Also ich hätte wirklich geglaubt fast, dass er Braunschweig runtergeht als Ulm zwischenzeitlich und dass sie sich zumindest diese Chance erarbeitet haben, auch wenn die letzten Wochen nicht so gut liefen, am letzten Spieltag das Ding noch rund machen zu können. Das hätte ich zwischenzeitlich nicht geglaubt. Michi, du?
Nein, das war auch so eines dieser Spiele in der Rückrunde. Fürth gegen Braunschweig, da haben sie auch 3-0 in Fürth verloren. Fürth hat nie, glaube ich, 3-0 gewonnen in der Saison so hoch. Also es war einfach, glaube ich, müsste der höchste Heimsieg gewesen sein, wenn ich mich nicht alles täusche. Und da waren sie einfach auch, das war okay, wie sie gespielt haben, aber es war jetzt auch nicht gut. Und fürth ist ja auch wahrlich keine Mannschaft, wenn man das Prädikat gut geben kann. Das sah für mich alles danach aus, dass sie diese Saison einfach dann vielleicht doch dran sind. Aber auch da wieder ein roter Pfaden. Das ist ein Unterschiedspieler. Also Raja Philipp ist wieder in Form, einfach ein sehr guter Spieler. Lionel Tempelmann wurde ja auch in einer der jüngsten Folgen mal besprochen. Auch ein sehr wichtiger Spieler. Ist halt einfach auch eine Mannschaft, die auch, wenn sie denn gut funktioniert, wenn sie als Kollektiv funktioniert, einfach auch in der Lage ist, Spiele zu gewinnen, auch mit dem HSV zu gewinnen. Und klar, das Momentum haben sie mehr auf ihrer Seite. Deswegen ist es auch schon ein Erfolg, dass sie da sein können. Ich glaube nicht, dass Münster und für die Spiele gewinnt. Also wenn Bratschweig gewinnt, gibt es gute Chancen, dass sie da auch von dem Platz noch wegrutschen. Aber andererseits haben wir den 1. Zündungspunkt ausgeklammert. Der spielt ja auch keine so gute Saison. Man hat mal gehofft, einen einstelligen Tabellenplatz zu erreichen. Wird nichts mehr. Also man hat jetzt auch vier Spiele nicht gewonnen. Also der hat auch noch was gut zu machen. Und dann nicht vielleicht sogar noch von deiner Härter-Marke überholt zu werden im Endspurt. Insofern vielleicht doch kein so schönes Spiel. Und der 1. Nürnberg ist ja auch eine wankelmütige, launige Mannschaft. Der kann da ja auch mal 2-0 gewinnen, wenn er will.
Das ist so. Gut. Jan Lukas, Butter bei die Fische. Wer muss in die Relegation und welche der beiden Teams bleiben direkt in der 2. Bundesliga? Deine Einschätzung?
Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass die Geschichte so geschrieben wird, dass Nürnberg Kräuter-Fürth rettet und dass Nürnberg, sagen wir so, dass Braunschweig kein besseres Ergebnis erzielt als Kräuter-Fürth. Ich glaube, ich traue, wie gesagt, für zu, dass sie sogar einen Punkt holen gegen den HSV. Sonst hätte ich den FC nicht als Zweitliga-Meister tippen können. Und selbst wenn nicht, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass Nürnberg trotz aller Rivalität gegen Braunschweig gewinnen wird. Ich glaube auch, dass Nürnberg ein bisschen was gut zu machen hat, weil, dass sie sich nicht die Vorwürfe gefallen lassen wollen. Gerade mit Klose als junger Trainer, dass sie irgendwie zweimal in entscheidende Rennen eingreifen, auch wenn ich das nicht so... also klar, ich darf eigentlich gar nichts zu sagen. Aber ich finde es nachvollziehbar, dass wir junge Spieler eingesetzt werden. Da müssen die anderen Vereine es halt in ihren eigenen Spielen machen. Trotzdem hat es natürlich einen blöden Beigeschmack und dementsprechend glaube ich, dass Nürnberg sich nicht hängen lassen wird. Ich glaube, dass Nürnberg sehr motiviert in das Spiel gehen wird und dementsprechend Braunschweig schlägt und Braunschweig daher in die Relegation geht und dementsprechend die wahrscheinliche Variante mit Münster gerettet eintritt und dann eben auch führt, die mit Abstand sicherlich das schwierigste Spiel haben, davon profitiert. Ich glaube nicht, dass Fürzich selber mit einem Sieg rettet. Ja, also wenn es nach mir geht, Unentschieden führt und Braunschweig verliert aber oder schafft es zumindest nicht zu gewinnen.
Also bleiben da mit 16.
Also Braunschweig 16., Ullven 17., logischerweise, und Regensburg ist sowieso 18. Darum geht es ja nicht mehr. Also ich sage, Braunschweig, Relegation.
Michi, wie sieht es da bei dir aus?
Ein kleiner Fun Fact, die eine Minute gönnen, nehmen wir uns noch. 2020 hat der 1. FC Nürnberg die Relegation bestreiten müssen, weil Fürth am letzten Spieltag gegen den Karlsruher SC verloren hat. Und damit der 1. FC Nürnberg noch nach einem 1 zu 1 in Kiel in die Relegation gerutscht ist, insofern könnte man sich da revanchieren jetzt und Fürth in die Relegation schicken. Aber schauen wir mal, ich setze tatsächlich auf die Kraft, die verbindende Kraft von Fans und Mannschaften. Es ist vor allem, dass man sich schön verabschieden will und es sieht zu gut aus für Preußen Münster. Vielleicht wiegt man sich auch schon zu sehr in Sicherheit nach diesen zwei Spielen. Ja, ich weiß Momentum und so weiter. Ich hoffe einfach, dass Preußen Münster nochmal in Ulm vielleicht kein so gutes Spiel macht und dass die Ulmer es nochmal gut meinen, mit Fürth und einfach da gewinnen. Ich will einfach keine Relegation mehr spielen. Auch so schön diese 2. Liga auch ist, aber irgendwann ist auch mal gut. Und das reicht dann. Also Preußen Münster spielt Relegation. Bitte?
Weil Braunschweig auch gewinnt.
Braunschweig gewinnt gegen Arsenal zu Nürnberg. Da ist die sogenannte Luft raus.
Dann haben wir schon wieder drei unterschiedliche Tipps. Das ist eigentlich perfekt. Ich habe es mir, und ich sage das nicht nur so, weil ich jetzt eure Tipps gehört habe, mich dementsprechend auslegen kann. Aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass ich jetzt, ich gehe voll auf das Momentum, ich gehe voll auf das Momentum und sage, dass sowohl Braunschweig als auch Münster– gut, Braunschweig hatte in den letzten drei Spielen keinen Moment, aber nehmen wir jetzt mal den Saison-Endspurt im Ganzen– sage ich, dass sowohl Braunschweig als auch Münster ihre Spiele gewinnen werden. Und Greuther Fürth verliert– das habe ich ja schon vorher getippt– gegen den HSV, weil der HSV-Zweitliga-Meister wird, kann ich ja den Tipp jetzt nicht im Nachhinein ändern. Und dann muss Greuther Fürth tatsächlich in die Relegation. Wahrscheinlich gegen Cottbus. Das wird man ja auch in der dritten Liga jetzt noch sehen. Ich sage aber, tippe ich einen Zweiter quasi, ich sage aber, dass Fürth die Relegation zieht. Also Fürth bleibt trotzdem in der Liga.
Das ist eine der wenigen Hoffnungen, dass diese ganzen Potenziale Relegationsteilnehmer eigentlich nur noch zwei sind, nämlich Cottbus oder Saarbrücken. Die müssten ja beide am letzten Spieltag verlieren und Hansa Rostock gewinnen, um vorbeizuziehen. Und die sind beide gar nicht mal in so guter Form. Pele Bolles ist ja auch schon wieder ausfällig geworden gegenüber einem seiner Spieler. Auch der 1. FC Saarbrücken hat zuletzt in Aachen verloren, durch die Chance vergeben, das Fass schon fix zu machen. Insofern sind die beide jetzt nicht in Form. Andererseits kennt man, dass das natürlich die anekdotische Evidenz ist. Meistens gewinnt der Dritte Ligist und ich glaube, statistisch ist das ähnlich. Also gewinnt öfter der Dritte Ligist als der Zweite Ligist. Wir brauchen nicht über Momentum reden in Fürth, wenn man gegen den HSV verliert. Ich hatte es vorhin gesagt, das wären dann 10 Spiele ohne Sieg. Andererseits von der individuellen Qualität müsste es eigentlich reichen. Ich habe zwei Zertesspiele gegen den Dritten Ligisten gesehen. Und das war trotzdem ein deutlicher Qualitätsunterschied zwischen Zweiter und Dritter Liga. Und wenn wir über die letzten Spiele dieser Zyklusmannschaft 24-25 in Fürth sprechen, vielleicht verabschieden Sie sich dann nochmal mit einem schönen… Aber nein, ich höre auf zu reden. Ich will das alles nicht erleben. Schluss.
Schluss ist das perfekte Wort, denn wir sind auch am Schluss dieser Sendung angekommen. Jan Lukas, Michi, das hat mir ganz, ganz großen Spaß gemacht. Ich wusste nicht, wie diese Sendung wird, weil es ja diesmal, wie gesagt, ein anderes Format geworden ist. Aber es hat mir großen Spaß mit euch beiden gemacht. Ich glaube, das hat sehr gut hingehauen. Ich spiele auch hier schon mal das Auto langsam ab, was den hier so langsam eintrudelt. Ich kann mich noch bedanken für das Zuhören. Wie gesagt, Rasenfunk-Unterstützung, das muss immer sein. Und ansonsten gehabt euch wohl. Habt einen wunderbaren letzten Spieltag, ihr alle. Und bis zum nächsten Mal. Macht's gut. Ciao, ciao und schöne Sommerpause.
Der Rasenfunk triebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.